hey guys Pete peppers here I'm going to
talk about Farm hero super saga and I'm
going to talk about one of the things
that you need to know that will help you
along the way and it's about these
boosters down here most of you have
probably been playing farm hero saga for
a long time and you know about shovels
right and farm here at super saw you
have a lot of herb in the original farm
heroes you have a lot of boosters some
recharge over time and then you have the
shovels and the shovels you buy with
magic beans which you collect along the
way
super saga doesn't have at least at this
point the rechargeable boosters but it
does have this watering can and the
gardening glove and those can be bought
with coins and I was never a big fan of
the rechargeable boosters that was an
aspect I didn't like about the original
game obviously as a video creator and
gamer myself I like to try to beat it
without any AIDS or boosters it's
actually important part of what I do but
the glue but the shovels in the first
game were cool because you could earn
the beans for free essentially and it
was okay to use those you know of course
we had companions and other things that
came along later but after around 100
level 100 you know you kind of needed
the shovels every single time and the
levels were just kind of designed that
way these are the new thing in the new
game and I wanted to do a quick video
because I think they'll probably be
equally as essential
now we don't have magic beans anymore we
have coins I'll talk about that a little
bit more so I've already bought these so
I'm just going to go ahead and click on
this the gardening glove the little
question marks that will open it and it
tells us it collects cropsey's and helps
with flowers ice buckets and more
so you know we could put it on a crop
see you can click around see it'll have
a different selection you could put it
on a flower it would grow that one stage
if we put it on a crop see it'll just
remove that from the board and you know
it says ice bucket so you can click on a
bucket you could do whatever so it's
kind of like a shovel it's almost
exactly the same but it's a gardening
glove instead so you you pick which one
you want to use it on I'll I just
started the level on it and actually
pick one with the situation but you know
you can use it to to make a match if you
want or something like that I don't see
a really obvious place to use it here so
I'm just going to go ahead and use it on
one of these these flowers click on the
check mark comes out and like I said it
works just like a shovel right the
watering can is more specific to the
farm here of super-super
mechanics click on the question mark
here selected crop seeds become a super
crop see so this helps with collections
you can put it on any crop see on the
board see where your error is hit the
check mark and then it grows and since
this is a collection we need it will
help us get that if this was a regular
crop tea that wasn't for a super
collection it would it would make it a
super crop see with the number five on
it so it can give you five extra for
your collection so a couple things to
keep in mind with these and most of you
will know from the shovels if you played
but if you're not if you're not a farm
heroes veteran once you use them or if
you start the level without them if you
click on the plus you can only buy them
for gold bars at this point so you can
see we have you know you could buy three
of them six of them nine of them four
different varieties of gold bars what
you have to buy you can't you can't earn
any of those at this point
same with the gardening gloves and
they're a little bit more expensive than
the watering cans and then we have this
basket this basket sort of like the
collect all rechargeable booster that we
had in the first game and they're even
more expensive but you get you know
multiples of them and that just a note
they remove all the cropsey's of one
color so you know if I wanted to collect
all my red right now I would click on I
would buy one of those and click on that
and it would collect all the red towards
my 100 all right so that's important to
note and I'm going to go ahead and quit
the level because you don't always have
to buy them for gold all right
when you start a level from anywhere on
the map
you know the one you're on or if you're
going back to play one you can buy them
for coins and coins is your coin totals
here you can see I have quite a few of
them so you do just earn them through
normal gameplay there is the social part
of this isn't really in full fling
because it's still in soft-launched
so you know you can also collect these
like you do beans as far as I know like
a people send you lives when your lives
are full when you collect you get coins
instead of lives because you can only
bank five lives at a time so you can get
coins that way you can get coins by
going back and playing a rancid level so
you could do this I would actually
recommend doing this early in the game
when rancid pops up go back and play
them on the easy levels because you can
see right here like my chance to play
him 450 which isn't a lot of coins is on
level 137 and it's actually difficult so
you have to actually beat the level to
collect the coins while you're getting
him so if you want to be a you know if
you really want to get ahead of things
and you want to collect a lot of coins
do it early in the game whenever he'll
pop up on the lower levels instead of
the higher levels he shows up every once
in a while do a rancid video later but
um you know that'll give you a better
idea but that's a part of it you also
get them for participating in the
country show see here it says rewards
the more levels you work the more coins
you get and those are also going to be a
lot easier in the beginning because
you're going to play a lot of levels
right in a row so you know by the time
you get to where I'm at in the game you
should have quite a few of these and so
they're basically free and the way you
use them to get your boosters is is when
you click on the level that you're on
you click on the shop
and you can see you have your different
choices here you get one 485 coins of
the watering can and you just click buy
now and continue you're taking back to
the shop and then you have your gloves
you buy one of those for 140 and you can
only buy one there used to be a glitch
in the original game where you could buy
the shovels really fast and they went
and register like you click back on it
and then you get 6 instead of 3 I don't
notice anything like that going on in
this game and you can see that we have
the other boosters that are available
and these ones in a higher quantity and
that just like they would be in game so
you can you can buy them for gold bars
if you want to stock up too but like I
said I don't like to do that most people
don't like to do that that's a
last-ditch effort but I do suggest
buying your 2 coin ones before you go
into any level because then you can use
them when you need them
so to recap you can see we have one each
here and we can use those whenever we
want
yeah and one of the reasons one of the
situations I used to use shovels a lot
in was to set things up so I'll just
look and see if there's one that will
pop up real quick just to explain that
for people who may not use them in the
past
so like here you know this isn't really
necessary but just to give you an idea
if I wanted to make this you know
four-way match here and I didn't want to
use a move because they don't take one
way from you see how 14 moves up at the
top I can put this on the red I'm going
to collect the points of the collection
points for this and it's going to make
this purple match and you can see that I
didn't lose a move there at all and
collect our super
and then I'll just show you one more
with the watering can we'll make this
one super by collecting it and then that
didn't take a move away either and then
we can pick it up with the five and goes
to our collection goals so this is a you
know it's a it's a basic thing that you
might not notice when you first start
playing make sure you buy them before
you enter the level because as I
mentioned they're going to be gold bars
after and if you get stuck towards the
end or you see a really good time to use
them they're essentially free and I'm
going to put a link here I had to use
one of the watering cans in my level 155
video that I just made so I'll have a
link there where you can see it in
action how I used it to finish the level
that's a pretty tough level so like I
said they the shovels became essential
in the regular farm here is about after
100 I think when I made my videos for
that years ago I made it through all 100
without using any boosters at all and
then shovels just became a regular part
of the game so make sure you learn how
these work make sure you get using them
and you start saving your coins so that
you'll be able to use them when you need
them it's not cheating or anything like
that because they're free if you earn
the coins and it just adds a different
dimension to the game thanks for
watching please like the video if you
found it useful subscribe to my channel
to get more videos like this and all the
latest level games that I play as soon
as they come out talk to you soon